your father is married yeah who do you
get Happy from your father having sex
with your mother you sleep like this but
you want to make you look bad because
why we live in a different Society
now am I happy about my father having
sex would you be happy to come someone
tell you so your father has sex with
your mother I mean I don't want speak
like that they did that's why we don't
speak like this do that's that's why do
we speak like this what you mean we
speak like like if I meet someone
stranger or anyone I said so your father
how old your mother was so your mother
has sex with your mother 25 want speak
like that but I know you saying it
because to make it look bad okay I'm
saying make it bad because why you
rather I use a different word married
her had sex with I don't mind if they
got married to sign paper it's about
having sex no no we don't speak like
that anyway so my point here is you know
about
presentism presentism is a logical
policy that people use in our time which
is they utilize our social dynamics
social Dynamic to judge people of the
past which no aacy but but people tell
me that Muhammad correct me wrong was
Muhammad a perfect moral example I going
to come with this yes should we act like
Muhammad now now listen to carefully not
everything Prophet Muhammad did we have
to follow it even the Muslim schol spoke
about it for example why don't you ask
Muslims why don't you get married to a
woman order the new 25 years old Prophet
Muhammad got married to a woman she was
20 years older than older than him why
no one saying we should follow him and
this because why this is not abnormal
now but because getting married to a 9
years old you become abnormal even
though 300 years ago universally we
something normal okay because the girls
back in those days was different so the
point here is not everything Prophet
Muhammad did we have to follow imal yeah
give me objective criteria why is moral
I don't believe there is objective
subjective so it's subjective so
therefore if your criteria is subjective
therefore you could be right or wrong so
you know sure well no there is no
objective you don't have objective
morality about about me no you don't
have objective morality no one has
objective morality morality you just
accepted your criteria is subjective
correct yeah all morality is subjective
I'm talking to you what's your name joh
John my name is Shi so Shi speaking to
John sh is not speaking to the whole
world not to everyone okay so let ask it
to each other so John you just admitted
your criteria is subjective yes which
mean could be right or wrong yes so
therefore you're not sure well I think
it's good to there's no there's no
objective reality ask are objective
subjective criteria which means you're
not sure yeah debate's right no you're
not sure if you're not sure can you
criticize something yeah of course you
can but you're not sure if it's right or
wrong you need to make up your mind
first hang on hang on hang on
me same time so my point is simply this
there is no so some people like you
believe you have objective morality
because the Invisible Man of
I don't believe in a man stop talking
about Christianity I'm not Christian I'm
Muslim the invisible
spirit I Spirit whatever whatever way is
your God Allah the creator of
everything he's given you OB I think
you're I think about I'm an atheist I
don't think the God you should the last
personam as an atheist as atheist you
don't have no objective criteria you
don't either you have subjective know
what you doing you know what you're
doing like someone I'm telling you you
raped a woman instead of Defending
yourself you K someone too what doing
you have to defend your this is what
people you just admitted John just admit
it to us have to start Shou over each
other Adit to ask from everyone here
that your criteria is subjective which
means everyone's criteria is sub I was
speaking about everyone of you okay
doesn't mean because you have subjective
there for everyone you don't know
everyone in the world do you okay so
stick to yourself so if your criteria is
subjective yes which means it could be
right or wrong yes so therefore you know
you have to make up your mind first
before then think about Prophet
Muhammad you agree I think so I
objectively I try to figure out what's
right and wrong partly by engaging
people in discussion we try and reason
our way to what's right or wrong and I
think that avoiding suffering is a good
thing to do and we have good reason to
believe that having sex with children
causes suffering okay first is not a
child this aacy doing he not a child
okay secondly again as an atheist is it
possible that man get married to a girl
she's 9 years old you could be right
well it could be yes it could be it's of
time could be the point of subjective
reality is to try and discuss it
listen philosophy is right subjectively
we try and reason and find our way to
what's right or wrong we just you could
just think okay what's written down in
this book came from the Creator
therefore that's all right and wrong the
shagging 9year olds that's all great we
could do that alternative we could say
live in the real world Adit that God
doesn't exist and try and work our way
out right and wrong from there don't I'm
not glad that there is no objective I
think the world would be better with
objective morality in reality there
isn't any so we have to go from there
and try and work out what's right or
wrong okay so a lot of people will say
because of the suffering forces because
of the risk of manipulation that a man
in the 50 having sex it's not because
firstly said to you is marriage only sex
for you is marriage only sex for you so
why use marriage why you because why I
know he's a buzz a
buzzz wait wait wait no no first John
again you are digress of the point you
cannot criticize anyone in the world
because it's waste of time because you
don't believe there is certainty do you
believe there's absolute certainty Abol
C so therefore you me I'll let you speak
for long you have to let me finish not
enough forget about me now let me finish
so therefore R dict you as a person
standing here who believe there's no way
for us to gain absolute certainty
speaking about any Prophet or any person
doesn't make any sense no that's not
true
a that's not true how okay are you you
can say that from this other thing that
we believe we value good
ide could you be wrong of my point
you know what Allah spoke about you John
you know Allah spoke about the Quan I
tell you Allah said Allah said about the
listen to this so powerful what you
demonstrating to us Allah mentioned in
the Quran 1,400 years ago the new
atheism movement yeah new atheism
movement Allah mentioned in the Quran
okay the meaning of it of course as one
of the scholar said Allah said in the
Quran about the story of Moses and
Pharaoh when Pharaoh asked Moses who is
the Lord of everything yeah so Moses
answered by saying the creator of the
heavens and the Earth and and that which
in between if you have any certainty The
Scholar one of the scholar said meaning
if you have no certainty that God exists
and you should be wored alone you have
no certainty about nothing else and this
exactly who you are because you don't
because you don't believe in God you
have no certainty about nothing else uh
I don't think what you mean by certainty
in terms of right in terms of morality
no let's Point subjective morality try
and work out okay are you certain
certainly you speaking to me right now
are you certain as close to certain as I
can be yes so there's doubt
or if someone someone says Oh no you're
plugged in at the Matrix I don't I don't
take that view very seriously but some
people say you've heard the argument
that we're all living in a a simulation
yeah I don't think take that don't take
that argument seriously but it could
theoretically be possible so it's
possible yeah if me and you were plugged
into a simulation and neither us about
if is it is it are you certain close to
certain a tiny Slither of Thug so
there's thou that you're not speaking to
me yeah of course there is thou speaking
to Tin of Doubt sure there is doubt yes
so there is doubt how would you know if
you are answer me this question how
would you know if you were plug against
the nature no I'm Ser I'm speaking to
you why how I I'm speaking to you you're
I show you if I take your phone you'll
be so certain to go to the police to
tell them sh talk my phone you it could
be talk my phone give me your phone
please if
you as I said there is a possib some
people people take possibility we live
in a simulation very seriously I don't
take it very seriously but it is so you
certain he speaking to me right now not
100% 99.99 my conclusion everyone
therefore you standing here criticizing
anything doesn't make any sense because
you because listen guys you want to
pretend you want to pretend that you
have objective morality I get it meish
let me finish let me finish let me
finish let meish understand more you
just admitted to me you have a reasons
for believing something wrong but those
reasons it could be wrong correct it
could be wrong take care of yourself
that's it done so standing here okay
guys
let so who gave you life who gave you
life I mean you should mean materially
who gave you life
my parents did obious so your parents
gave you life my
parents gave you life your parents so so
if your parents gave you life yes so
therefore L dictate now your parents
have a power to give a life correct well
to create others yes that's what we're
here for so when you die how come your
parents cry for you why they cannot give
you life again if it was AB them in the
beginning wait what you why my parents
can't resurrect me if you if your
parents had the had the power to give
you a life we were nothing yes L dictate
they will be able to give you power when
you are something that's loal if someone
is able if someone's able to make a car
from scratch is able to fix it if it
breaks down you understand so therefore
if your parents gave you a life and you
have to stick to it so your parents give
you life no no no so just because my
parents have the possibility to create
me it therefore means they did so
certain the power close to certain as we
get to yes take
Li that's outcome aism no certainty no
certainty all certain
all certain about that you certain
firstly
firstly firstly firstly Prophet muhamed
was married to a girl and she was 9
years old
married they cons
marri if you talk about
sex you think only sex your father and
your mother only have sex okay so marri
married when they Mar only sex or not so
therefore why you why you Muhammad you
men the I know why cuz it's a bad words
that you want to and I'm telling you
okay is it wrong for someone as
atheist as as a atheist he has no
problem objectively for a man sleep with
a baby two months old do you have
problem would rather do you have
objectively no there's no objective
that's it that's my point so you could
be right pardon you could be right well
yes it could be it could be right sleep
with two months and it's
Muhammad Muhammad he he said it could be
like for a man to speak with two months
old andet Muhammad take care of yourself
is done
know take care ofself byee